foreign
the three Muslims now before we get
started with the stream with Vlad and
yugen we actually have a very quick
announcement so we are currently
partnered with seven Earth uh seven
Earth brand or sorry uh we're currently
partnered with seven Earth Studios a new
higher end brand based on Islamic motifs
and Islamic history their collection
drops this Friday at 3 P.M Pacific
Standard Time and all collections are
limited and no collection is sold twice
so just like that this collection will
be limited and will not be sold again
and after 14 days the sale will close or
more likely when we sell out everybody
that enters their email in the link
below
And subscribe to the email list we'll
get 10 off their purchase and a free
essential tea and also lastly 10 of the
profits will be donated to the Masjid
and Norway and the earthquake victims
and as you can see I'm wearing two of
their fits right now and it is
absolutely astonishing great quality and
looks phenomenal especially on me if I
do say so myself with that being said if
I add let's bring the Gaston inshallah
there we are hello everybody all right
welcome boys how you guys doing good
good I decided to get started been a
while been like two months three months
in the making yeah
me and Angel we uh we're first
introduced to you guys on that uh that
one video uh you made a while ago that
we reacted to I don't know if you got a
chance to see that but um yeah I think I
I think on that stream I uh
send a donation just letting you guys
know I saw it and uh yeah so yeah it was
cool but the reason why I didn't want to
just jump straight into a live stream is
because you you know you don't really
know anything even the basics or the
surface of the religion and uh or
anything about Islam and you don't wanna
you wanna know a little bit before you
jump in so yeah I thought we'd do that
first which we did yeah so we know like
some of the basics obviously we still
have a lot to learn but the like the
very basic Foundation is starting to
form so yeah I think absolutely and and
we respect that very much you know I
think that's exactly the approach uh
that young men like us should take we
search for the truth we understand what
we're talking about before we jump into
things so I respect that greatly but
before we get into all that we actually
want to learn a little bit more about
you guys uh we know your channels is is
fairly new so I think one thing
everyone's wondering is why do you guys
decide to start making reaction videos
and launch your Channel
you got this boss okay so uh as you guys
might know we are like big fans of these
controversial figures like Andrew Tate
uh snico Sonny and um they all started
making content about this and it just
kind of like popped up on our feet since
we were fans of them and we were like
you know this looks kind of interesting
so we decided to hop in on it and watch
a few videos and react to it and you
know people ended up liking it from the
get-go so we were like okay well people
like it so we might as well keep going
yeah all right and how was your
relationship with the content and what
you were watching how much did you enjoy
actually watching these these videos
reacting to them
um well when it came to certain stuff
obviously you're gonna like certain
videos more than others be but not
everything is necessarily about
enjoyment some things you just need to
know and also like you know like
sometimes you're in school right and
you're learning about something you're
not necessarily sitting there to learn
it just because it's all enjoyment and
all enthusiasm sometimes you just need
to be educated right so to sit here and
say every second of every single video
was all about enjoyment obviously not
but it was there was videos that did
stand out and were fun to learn
especially engaging with the comments
everybody correcting us everybody's
saying No this is why we do this and the
most important I think part of it was
engaging with the community and them
saying hey guys react to this and kind
of allowing
our comment section to guide us down
where they want us to go you know so in
terms of reacting to the Islamic content
the bar everything else they kind of
guided us through it you know all right
that's amazing and it's really
interesting that you you mentioned that
so what was the response of the viewers
and the Muslims in which direction do
you think they guided you
um I think they probably picked up on
what we liked like our kind of humor or
kind of like how you know we bounce off
each other in the videos we like to like
talk to each other
um we also like to hear something out
and then rationalize why someone might
believe or might not believe in that and
then we give our opinion on it and so I
think they just guided us down you know
based on how you know we talk to each
other like if we were way more serious
like very very serious no we made no
comments or user or or engaging with our
personalities maybe then they got us
down a different way but I think they
also wanted us to enjoy ourselves while
reacting to comments which is why uh we
we always started videos when it's like
animated we're like always like yeah
let's go because it's like it'll engage
with us because you know it's more fun
that way you know absolutely absolutely
all right that's beautiful to hear so
with that being said
at what point because you had mentioned
before that you wanted to learn a little
bit more about Islam get the basics down
uh before jumping on the stream so
how do you feel in regards to where
you're you know understanding of Islam
is now do you guys feel a lot more
confident in your understanding of it I
mean for me
in in comparison to the average
I'm going to say American I know they
get a lot of slack they're always the
you know I mean they're always the the
person that or the uh country that gets
the most slack but compared to the
average person who isn't a Muslim I'd
say we're far more knowledgeable than
them but then if you go speak to a shake
or one of you guys you know we look like
toddlers you know what I mean so uh in
comparison to the average person we
probably know quite a bit more but then
you know if we're getting into the
fundamentals you know Dr Zakir we always
talk about them like you know verse 187
and then he names it the entire line and
then you know he can even cite from the
Bible and then he can cite from this and
this and this and it's like no we're
nowhere near that but we're doing well
yeah like we wouldn't try to debate
anybody in knowledge but like you guys
because we did watch a Dr zakira video
with this woman it was just like uh
asking questions and he would answer and
then she would like loop around and ask
the same thing and it just got nowhere
and I would not want to be like that
like if somebody more knowledgeable says
something I'll be like okay yeah like
they know more than I do I feel you and
in the case of Dr zakira Knight he
nobody's on his level he is his own
breed he's always his own specialty may
Allah bless him and um that's why we're
here you know honestly I would liken us
way more more to you guys than someone
like Zachary Knight you know we're just
three guys chilling looking for to have
you know conversation talk about
religion God and all that stuff so
honestly I think that this is the the
perfect setup here so other than the
channel itself and the feedback you got
from the viewers
what interests you about Islam what what
made you want to keep looking into it
you want to start
um like I'm very interested in what is
like considered Haram since before I
knew about Islam it was very new to me
and I'm like why why can't you eat pork
or why can't you do this and these seem
like very simple things to somebody who
has never followed anything like that so
it was very surprising to me and I'm
like
dang I mean
all right and then once we got to learn
about it we understood why they do it
and why that works and we're like okay
like if you're a Muslim you should
respect it and we respect that also
yeah for me I feel like it's a lot more
um it's a lot more down the lines of
where so we got interested in into
making the content at the start you know
make a few videos instantly right
instantly pop off blow up everywhere
timeline here there there again DMS from
this guy getting DMS from that guy do
this do that and a big thing is you know
the amount tens thousands tens of
thousands of comments react to this
react to this react to this so not only
is it you know educational and you know
wanting to actually learn because
regardless of what anybody says of like
oh you only do it for subs and whatever
well not really like I've had you know
Tick Tock accounts personal Tic Tac
accounts with 220 000. I've worked with
Sony I've worked with zico I know how to
blow things up and I could do it without
uh reacting to uh I guess a popular
topic but it's genuinely super fun to
see good feedback people saying we love
your reactions like me and vladderly sit
here looking at our second monitor here
going through comments all love the
reaction you guys are so funny we react
to this or you know it's stuff like that
so uh we genuine genuinely enjoy
engaging with uh those kind of kinds of
people you know
all right absolutely said
interesting blood you said you were
looking into it because of the uh the
whole Haram things and you were just
kind of questioning like oh why isn't
Saddam and this and that that was like
the hug the initial hook yeah yeah so
with the answers you got like would you
say you're you're satisfied with those
answers did you did it meet your
expectations
uh for the post for the most part all
the questions that I did have we either
answered in another video that we
reacted or in the comments so like
pretty much all the questions we have do
get answered so
as far as now I am happy with the
answers I received yeah I mean he's very
haramed as I'm telling you
so am I so I can't say anything I'm
pretty uh listen I love my poor one of
the comments I'm looking at right now
was like uh you know in one of the
videos though when you were talking
about how much you love pork so I kind
of wanted your guys's opinion on uh pork
and you know not just from a law why why
you wouldn't eat pork but kind of delve
into like scientifically if you know any
reason why you would never consume pork
because I love it personally yeah which
pork are you eating are you talking
about bacon so all all of it so I'm from
Ireland in Ireland we have black pudding
which is Pig's blood with barley we have
um we have um the pork belly uh we have
so we eat all that we eat everything of
the pork in Ireland we have like bacon
which is not like strips of bacon it's
like a type of ham from the pig and we
have like all kinds of uh different
things it's it's actually the worst
country you could be from if in terms of
like eating poor it's one of the world
everybody's eating you know I mean pork
loin ham bacon you know everything so
you you said you said Ireland yeah you
know what's crazy bro one of the first
uh reverts that we had on the channel
was from Ireland Kevin was he yeah and
he still lives there yeah I haven't seen
that it's a very old video bro it was
like our first like brother that came
and accepted Islam on the show yes
that's it so you can't use that as an
excuse you can do it as well no no no
what I'm saying is that if you look
Irish population 99.5 Catholic Roman
Academy 99 white you know
um very I don't want to say racist
very ignorant so like they'd be well all
the stereotypes you could name they
would say them so you know that's that's
kind of like and I'm lucky that I moved
from that environment which is I still
love it like just because they're
ignorant it doesn't mean they're bad
people necessarily but
um I kind of enjoyed moving to Canada
where listen I walk down the street
somebody could be black white blue
Avatar you don't know who's walking down
the street here anybody can be from
anywhere all the different religions and
cultures and so when you come over here
you kind of get a little bit more
educated and then you can speak on
topics with more certainty as well
absolutely yeah yeah very beautiful
um
yeah Canadian culture is beautiful we
actually have I think a really strong
Muslim Community here like in the GTA
like the greater Toronto area I don't
know if you guys are familiar well lots
of mosques lots of what we call Massage
it and a really strong Community here
um isn't Ireland like like a huge
supporter of Palestine
uh I'm not too sure um that former
policy ones that we just gotta close the
lines because it looks sure absolutely
yeah all right and boys if you don't
mind just real quick adjusting the
camera
sure because Vlad is cut off by the
display sign
oh let's let's do that no that's
terrible why not
can you make it a little there you go
that's it there you go boys
that looks nice all right so so okay
actually let me ask well first let me
say for the audience and ask for the
audience because I think everyone's
wondering this are you guys Brothers
you know what we actually talked about
this right before the stream started and
people like oh people think we're
brothers and I'm like I mean we don't we
don't got the same hairstyle I don't
think we really look alike no so no
we're not Brothers but do we look
similar is that like yeah
we're European man oh is this is it the
eyes and the or just white with blue
eyes okay yeah yeah the hair color is
very similar to the eyes yeah
I can see it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
absolutely all right but but to get so
which one is Vlad and which one's you
again Vlad so actually I should correct
it so I'm from Ireland and in Ireland uh
e-o-g-h-a-n is derivative from Owen uh
so it's Owen but it's spelled
e-o-g-h-a-n Gaelic Gaelic language and
GH is silence and I I forget why the e's
in there but listen like if you look at
uh Ava which is usually Ava it's a-o-b
uh b b h e and with a father so like
that's Gaelic
um and so yeah that's why that that's
that so yeah Vlad represents
okay yeah that's super cool man super
cool so Owen I do want to answer your
question I think the best fit to answer
would probably be fired not to throw you
on the spot
but I feel like this is a little more
your your Realm the Haram police
not today boy not today
um the question was about pork why you
wouldn't yeah like obviously because
it's very easy for you guys to
conceptualize why you would say well
Allah told us not to so don't but even
me I respect that obviously if a lot if
you're a Muslim and Allah tells you not
to do something that's all the reasoning
you need but from somebody who's maybe
more
um you know they're like well that's all
good and well but I need more of a
reason what would be the best argument
for you to say listen
get off pork
so number one a lot of the illnesses
that we see in human beings today
science has proven this is from having
pork
and majority of the reasons come from
the fact that they do consume their own
feces
and a lot of the time a lot of parasites
bacteria viruses they stay in that and
it basically just lives in that and
consumes it now when they do prepare it
a lot of it it's processed it's frozen
there's no proper refining process
there's no Halal slaughtering process or
anything like that so it's kind of dirty
to begin with and then when we consume
it it's no wonder why today's studies
are proving that a lot of these
illnesses are associated with pork
consumption from bacon either pork
brisket whatever you name it
all right that I mean that's that's a
sound reasoning to me I mean we kind of
got the same answer from Dr Dr Zakir he
kind of said the same touch on the same
thing obviously he's he just went he
spilled for 10 minutes I think he went
crazy
um yeah for me like
um obviously my that's that's mine is
anecdotal in terms of what I can see and
uh for me personally
um pork
like I've never seen bad side effects
maybe I'd have to quit stop eating pork
for like a month or two and see if
there's any benefits of like physically
feeling
but um yeah for me personally I've
always been eating pork and I don't know
I just don't yeah yeah and like a lot of
the time things don't affect every
single person it doesn't mean things but
not generally harmful so for example
someone might consume alcohol I don't
recommend this and they might claim oh
I've had no subjective harms but someone
else might it's not that everyone who
drinks is gonna end up as that drunk
driver per se and that's why Allah in
the Quran says that it's not the alcohol
doesn't have benefits but Allah says
that the harms far outweigh the benefits
and that's where it's hold on
yeah I mean that makes sense to me like
uh I think the best example of this
would be like you know some one person
might do heroin and another might do
heroin one might not get addicted one
might get addicted everybody's different
some people are more are less tolerant
and more tolerant to certain substances
than certain foods but um yeah that's a
pretty logical reasoning like especially
if if it's not if there's no benefits of
pork besides protein and you can get it
from something else then it makes sense
to me but I'm probably gonna still be
Haram at least for a little longer I'll
probably still have bacon but that's
just how it is yeah I have a bacon with
my eggs for a little extra protein you
know I gotta gotta keep the gains up is
like is it like a one-time thing could
you just have like one bad piece of
bacon and like you get sick or is it
over time or it's that that's that's
what it is yeah
my stepmom she used to love bacon
because Puerto Ricans uh in in this
tradition it's just like the Irish for
this poke in almost everything right and
she she just had one bad meal where the
meat was better the pork was bad
this woman was food poison for almost
three months straight wow
this is not to say this is not to say
that we're all like everyone's gonna get
poisoned for three months straight it's
just say like it's not to be taken
lightly that this is a dirty piece of
food that you're eating yeah that would
be a wake-up call and a half
yeah for real it's kind of like uh you
know the the one person that doesn't
wear a seat belt in the car and you're
like put a seatbelt on because if you do
get in a crash you got to be ready and
then they don't do it and it keeps going
keeps going keeps going and then again
makes sense and you both have watched a
fair amount of uh just like Islamic
content and reacting so one common theme
you perhaps picked up on is that we
prefer prevention rather than dealing
with the consequences yeah
yeah yeah uh why why would you do it why
would you you know get involved in first
place when you could just never touch it
or never do so yeah yeah yeah makes
sense bro have you ever had beef bacon
no bro it's so much better is it I'll
have to try I'll have to take your word
for it because I've never tried it but
I'm sure it'll just please I love beef
hey please take my word man I wasn't
Muslim my entire life so I used to eat
bacon before this and then once I
started having the beef bacon it's it
was better bro I'll take your word for
it but one thing that isn't better is be
Fred that is not nearly as good as pork
rib and you you're Muslim but say it get
it good no no listen listen listen
that's it it's not it's not like that
it's um I think it's all about the
preparation like who prepares the meat
no I agree and if it takes if they take
time with it you know like they slow
cook it overnight and do all that stuff
man like it comes out banging no matter
what yeah and like beef listen beef is
if I was to pick one or the other I'll
be some picking beef uh beef you could
do so much steak ground beef uh brisket
like this and as you said I've never
heard of it but you know beef bacon but
you can do so much with a cow you know
you get milk from a cow you get cheese
butter from a cow you get a lot more
things from a cow and
so if I was to pick I would pick a cow
yeah yeah yeah yeah so you have no
excuse you have no excuse bro I mean my
excuse is that uh
I I don't really see he hasn't been
slapped with that food poisoning yeah
but bro like let's let's again
let's take a little preventative measure
here bro you know God willingness
doesn't happen to you
thank you bro
so on the note of Islam
I was I'm actually very curious so
through all your reactions what would
you say are the things that you really
appreciate about Sam are some of the
things that really stand out to you
about stem I think I can actually go
first on this I love the community uh I
think that if you look at the where
where I'm from Ireland strong sense of
community
um everybody's because you're white your
Chris you're a Catholic white Catholic
and you're all playing the same Sports
all of the same accent everybody's the
same there's a strong community of
people there and with it with Islam it's
not even necessarily the traits that I
described in terms of how you look and
how you sound it's more that there's one
goal for everybody to get to Jannah and
so the sense of community when you're
talking about non-believers or even
Believers where you're like you know you
see your bro drinking alcohol maybe he's
a Muslim and you're like hey you check
them you're like hey what are you doing
like stop doing that and it's like also
wanting you to succeed and do well
because even the non-believers because
they look at you and they go hey man
listen this is this is your purpose and
worst case scenario you live a healthy
happy and friendly life you know what I
mean and at the end there's nothing even
if you couldn't convince the to make
God's real the end of it you're like you
live a happy healthy friendly life you
know what I mean with without short-term
Pleasures so that's kind of what I love
about the Islamic community which you
don't really find in I I'd say maybe
Judaism you would still find that sense
of community but not nearly as much as
Islam Islam are more outspoken in terms
of like the internet at least and uh Pro
in person too I have a crazy story about
an Islamic family too I think I'll tell
later yeah I wanted to add something
it's a sense of innate belongingness is
very easy so when you look at Judaism a
lot of them are born into Judaism and
they're ethnically Jewish whereas with
many other communities the same thing
when it comes to Islam it's from all
different races bro and when you see the
community coming together depending on
no matter what color you are no matter
what religion you were born into no
matter what country you're born into no
matter what color of your skin it gives
you a different level of community it's
not like oh you know what I'm forced to
be with this community because I was
born into it but it's almost like it
doesn't matter where you're from but I
believe in one God you believe in one
God we're both Muslim this is all that
matters at the end of the day
yeah and I also like how
um people portray themselves like they
follow the rules and everything and like
in this modern world you can identify as
anything and be half naked everywhere
and yeah I like that there's strict
rules against that and that you know you
portray yourself in a well
like in a good way that's also the one
thing about Islam that we that I noticed
from the reactions and also just the
comments and seeing you guys and seeing
everybody else is that like if you guys
watch fresh and fit you know when you
watch it the girl will be you know
she'll have two she'll she'll slept with
300 guys having only fans be rude to her
husband can cook beware be half naked on
the show and then say she's a Christian
and you're like what's what's going on
here and then but you won't you don't
find that nearly as much if ever with I
mean we watched a video conservative
versus liberal uh Muslims but I
genuinely don't believe that people take
them seriously I think that's just a
very small minority of people who are
confused
um and so yeah but when you look at
Christianity I think not to say that you
know you're a bad person if you're
Christian but I just think the sense of
community because I'm I'm a Catholic at
heart like I I I've you know done my
confirmation I've done everything and so
uh you know growing up in that community
in Ireland it's good because everybody's
Catholic and everybody there's a strong
sense of togetherness but anywhere like
that's not like that is very like as I
said in my example like 300 bodies and
your Catholic or Catholic or Christians
like what are you doing here like how
can you just say these things so yeah
yeah bro you know what it is
in Islam we have this thing known as a
taqwa have you guys heard of that in the
videos that you've been reacting to
okay
yeah so very simply put talk away is a
guide consciousness
like being aware of God so you are
literally holding yourself as a Muslim
you hold yourself to this very high
level because you know that you're
always being watched every single action
everything you do it's always being
watched and that's why you see the
Muslims they have the best character
like they're always trying to do the
best that they can like you see Muslims
they get into businesses together
they'll have the best transactions why
because bro they understand that they're
being watched by this this thing
right this thing that has complete
control over their life and complete
control over what's going to happen to
them once they pass and they're no
longer in this life so why would they do
someone wrong and just for some money
here when they know that ultimately
they're going to be punished it's like
when we were kids and our parents were
watching us like we were definitely on
our best behavior whereas when the
parents weren't watching us we were a
little liquidy you know what I'm saying
yeah 100 percent
yeah that's a really amazing thing to
have it would be fantastic if more
people also thought like that yeah
absolutely and that's it's a very
interesting point both that you guys
made and the point that I have brought
up because it really shows I'd say the
difference in belief uh for each way
like if you look at liberalism right why
do they live these kind of lives it's
because liberalism inherently is telling
them just do whatever pleases you focus
on yourself please yourself don't care
about anybody else don't care about the
greatest exactly exactly and it's
unfortunately very very degenerate Islam
is the complete opposite Islam is like
listen you need to put yourself whatever
you're feeling whatever you want aside
for the greater go to the whole
Community because that's even better and
on top of that when you do that God will
reward you and increase you and whatever
urges you have God will give you a Halal
alternative for it for example instead
of sleeping around with people God makes
it easy for us to get married
and he's blessed us with spouses you
know how beautiful is that and now
there's commitment in the home there's
proper parenting and structure for the
kids
um you have a Halal Outlet both the the
husband and wife and there's uh you know
proper set gender roles for them as well
uh and also in Islam you know I like the
way you mentioned before about the
community Allah he actually says in the
Quran that he created us in different
you know races ethnicities backgrounds
so that we can get to know each other
subhanallah and he said if we willed we
could have made you all just one big
nation yeah lots of tests than that yeah
yeah yeah that's a that's the best exam
my uh Auntie came over here for a summer
and this is so in Ireland that it's the
best example because in Ireland
everybody's very ignorant together it's
almost like the I've never left my town
in 30 years kind of vibe there you know
what I mean like that kind of very like
in your own shell maybe you have one
trip to Spain every once in a while and
when you're there you look around like
who are these weirdos you know it's that
kind of vibe and then so she came over
here to Canada I remember she didn't
even say it to be me she was very polite
and um in Canada we have a lot of
indigenous people we went to an
indigenous grounds native people
I swear to God she went she went up to
the person the person she went you know
when I was younger I watched a lot of
cowboys and Indians and I just went oh
God what's good and I was just like it
was and then like literally if you could
press the vine boom sound boom I would
have like I would have pressed it right
there because she kept going she was
like I've been watching him for 20 years
Cowboys and Indians press it again like
it was terrible and it was so awkward
but she you know what I mean but it's
not even trying to be mean she had the
best intentions but it's just the way it
is over there you know what I mean yeah
yeah absolutely absolutely
um the second time I wanted to ask where
you're from I'm not gonna do that
publicly but like in Canada because I'm
thinking of the different places this
could have occurred because I could say
uh I guess Saskatchewan that's fine I
mean I mean are they gonna laugh on
every house
if you want to say hi come knock on the
house we don't mind I don't mind hey bro
you never know man these people nowadays
they'd be finding your IP address real
quick
listen listen
there's two of us I am six foot five he
is six foot six he's got we'll stand up
lean muscle so you know I'll get the
measurements don't don't go don't go
over here yeah hey that's that's a
problem
absolutely absolutely
so
um Owen you've mentioned that uh you
grew up Catholic and Christian and I'm a
bit curious about you know your your
backgrounds because whenever someone
looks into a new religion they have a
whole history of their own beliefs in
respects to God in respect to religion
how they live life what they believe in
general so I would really appreciate if
you guys could share a bit of your
upbringing in your background in that
boss all right well so ever since I was
a kid um I was pretty much Christian
because my mom was and she would like
Take Me to Church and tell me to
practice all these things but uh I was a
kid so I really never really thought
anything about it I'm like okay well my
mom somebody go to church so I'm gonna
go to church and then she tells me to
stand up I stand up and all that thing
so I was just like following the rules
until
I grew up and then I started thinking
I'm just like
meh like I kind of fell out of it
honestly I really didn't do much
after that but then I was like I'll say
the main reason I believe that there is
absolutely something there is like I
always go back to this point but like
how did it how did anything start right
the universe is like way too precise for
for it to be like
a coincidence just something happens the
Big Bang how'd the big bang happen or
anything like that so I first started
off Christianity and it still is for the
most part but now we're
learning about this and it's interesting
so I would like to know like
most of the religion before I make any
like the big decisions life-changing
decisions so right now I'm just I'm just
on my own ground just just learning I'm
just learning yeah absolutely and that's
beautiful man I think there's immense
Beauty in just sitting back and learning
and absorbing and just you know letting
the Creator whatever his way is whatever
his religion is letting him guide you to
what the truth is exactly yeah I think
it's amazing so how about you Owen
uh For Me grew up uh Roman Catholic went
to church every Sunday you know San Neo
sit down you know at church be like can
I sit no you know that that going on you
talk too loud pinch on the thigh talk
way too loud twist the ear drag your own
church you know you know how it is maybe
you don't but that's just how it was and
uh yeah so grew up every Sunday for the
first I'd say 14 15 years of my life my
dad's a pipefitter so he was away as
soon as we came to Canada he started
working uh out uh for he was doing like
I mean it's it's changed a lot but you
know he might have done like 14 like
maybe nine and fives or like that's like
now but he might have done 21 days three
days off so he's gone you know he's
working out at camp
and so kind of fell out of it like that
but I was never
like to say that I was ever truly uh
like I'm Catholic obviously in nature
but to say I was ever truly like a
devout is just played out wrong so I was
never a devout Catholic but
um grew up Catholic
and yeah I mean everybody is Catholic in
Ireland so it's just something you wear
you're just you're just Catholic but
um never I I probably I'll say this I
probably know
the same level in terms of knowledge of
Christianity and Islam to be honest with
you that's like in the three months that
we spent just reacted the videos
I probably learned and caught up so that
that tells you how much you know I mean
it just tells you how much I was
listening in church but you know the
same gospels over and over and like just
being like just tuning out you know
being like yeah as a kid you don't have
the attention span for that you want to
go go do go outside go run around my uh
my dad would uh so what he would do is
up at half seven you know get get ready
nice get away you gotta dress nice if
somebody sees you at church not looking
good that's not it's you I look good
shower buttoned up you know go to church
and he'd say on the car ride he's like
if you're quiet we'll go to the shop
afterwards and if we were quiet which we
never were but he you know you can't
tell a kid you know if you're quiet I'll
get you stuff and then after just be
like yeah you weren't quiet enough they
don't understand so you got to do it
anyway so we always went to the shop
gave us the Euro candy so it was
incentivized my dad was just it was more
like a publicity almost it's like in
Ireland there's a lot of Pride so it's
like you go there my dad my dad's
looking probably at everybody else you
know they're he's like wow people are
looking at my dad like wow he's buying
stuff he's taken four kids to church and
they're all being quiet but they don't
know what's actually going on behind you
know with the candy you know I mean they
don't know they just think we're great
kids we're not but there was incentives
you know
I see I see well so where are you at now
in terms of my faith
yeah in terms of just your beliefs in
general like my beliefs I mean I I don't
think I can explain all my morals and
you know a few seconds but I could I I
could say in terms of my faith I'd say
uh I'm pretty I'm fierced so I believe
as Vlad said there's something but I but
I I don't believe like you die and you
just dirt and you're just in the void of
like nothingness I think that's a very
nihilistic very like depressive very
like live your best life man do drugs
and do this and nothing matters like I
feel like that's a very uh nihilistic as
I said Viewpoint of life so for me I
believe there's something which is why I
always recommend regardless of religion
regardless of if you believe live
as if you're the you're trying to be the
best person you possibly can be in terms
of your own physical health mental
health other people be the best person
you can be
um so that's kind of where I'm at so I'm
kind of at the point where I'm like
listen I'll treat people nice same way
you were saying in a business deal in in
Islam you wouldn't screw someone over
because God's always watching my idea is
that God's watching but I don't know
what God you know I don't know yeah who
it is but I just feel the prayer I feel
that presence of like
not necessarily in a feeling or in a
physical feeling but it's more just like
listen man this world is crazy there
definitely has to be something out there
looking at us yeah yeah and that feeling
is actually innate to every single human
being there was actually a study
conducted I think at Oxford University
uh and they took a bunch of even like
kids and they asked the young kids of
different backgrounds different
upbringings if they believe in a God or
a higher power every single one of them
said yes so that's something that's just
you know all humans are created with so
I think that's a very beautiful thing
and what about you Vlad
um where I'm at right now yeah
um same thing it's not like at every
action I think that there's somebody
watching me it's more also for myself
that I'm like I don't want to be a bad
person like yeah it's just
why would I like I have sympathy for
others and I'm like I
why would I be mean for no reason right
and I'm just like yeah I'm just be as
nice as I can to everybody so yeah for
even my own sake I don't want to be like
hated or anything like that that's also
like well you know a thought that I had
just occurred to me I haven't really
thought it out but let's see how this
goes guilt the emotion guilt yeah if you
think of like a species in terms of
evolution right people always say you
know humans have evolved to be the best
versions in terms of collaboration and
this and this and that why would in
terms of self uh goal if you want to be
the most powerful richest most
successful person why would you ever
have guilt because you were trying to
make the most money possible right why
would you have an emotion that holds you
back from doing things that would
further the success of your nature as a
human right it makes no sense so it's
like how did guilt get instilled as an
emotion or jealous or like not jealousy
sorry but like feeling bad almost how is
that an emotion that humans can feel
so if it doesn't progress yeah sympathy
or empathy how's that emotion you can
feel if if it doesn't progress you in
any way it actually holds you back right
yeah I actually I think I have an answer
for that if you if you're interested in
hearing it I am so
you mentioned success and goals I think
the more important question is what is
the goal and what is success because if
you look at it like in the grand scheme
of things people as a society you notice
that God has created us to live all
together amongst each other
can you imagine a society without
empathy or a society without sympathy
where people know just don't care for
each other at all have no regard there
would be no collaboration there would be
no group mentality there would be no
Society at all and then humans would
probably just perish being the
individuals that they are so I think
that there's a greater goal and a
greater aim to succeed in which is the
greater good of society yeah
yeah I agree yeah would you say that's a
fair estimation yeah I'd agree with that
yeah I'd say I'd say
I I don't know like because obviously as
a as a Muslim you're like I'm doing this
because I want to get into Jinnah and
you know I I don't like why would you
want to be in Hellfire that makes no
sense so there's a there's a clear
objective so it's very easy for a Muslim
to answer that question the morality
question why be moral it's very easy
well I don't want to be I don't want to
go to Hellfire but then as a just a
theist person or not even theist let's
cut that out because you could say
because God could be watching just as an
atheist pure bred 100 atheist you could
say well why are you being nice what's
the point right if you're just gonna sit
in the ground and be dirt yeah then
really what's the point okay that that
feeling bad you feel bad but then why do
you care about feeling bad you know what
I mean why do you care about feeling bad
if you're just gonna sit in the dirt
right yeah okay I got you bro so I want
you to think about this
all right
if you're guilty
it's going to it's basically just an
indicator it's letting you know
something about maybe something else so
let's say you uh you did something wrong
like you really hurt someone else like
let's say you you did them dirty and you
feel guilty about this this is something
that's letting you know yo I did
something wrong I should probably
correct the corset correct my my
character and my actions and what I did
you know I'll make amends so to speak
now imagine you didn't have this guilt
you will continue and you would even get
further and further uh regressing into
this uh behavior of doing people dirty
now imagine you're doing something like
watching explicit adult content
all right you know how bad this is you
know how destructive this is and a part
of you feels guilt for watching other
people
have intimacy and then you getting off
to this
so now if you didn't have that guilt
because again an atheist they say oh
well we're gonna die anyway so might as
well just enjoy yourself is that
Hedonism if you don't care about what's
gonna happen or if you don't have no
moral compass here well then you're just
going to keep doing this thing that is
not beneficial to you it's actually
poison to you it's making you regress as
a man it's making you into a degenerate
individual but hey
that's the guilt would actually
ring some alarms it would show you hey
yo yo something's going on here so this
is why
we have guilt as humans at least from my
understanding no I completely agree with
that actually but then like that's
that's actually a great example of why
you have guilt
and what I was pointing at more is from
an atheist perspective how do you
explain guilt how do you explain guilt
from a evolutionary perspective of why
would humans have an intrinsic guilt
feeling if it didn't progress you in
this hedonistic life if in terms of
because people say scientists say you
evolve as a human to adapt to the
circumstances you're in so why would you
hold on to feelings that would regress
you from making more money doing this to
like you know what I mean all these bad
feelings it's because you have a moral
compass well why do you have a moral
compass because it must have been given
to you or must have been intrinsic right
there has to be an intrinsic moral
purpose right yeah yeah and that is a
great point that is a great point
because you're touching on this this
more philosophical idea that you know
atheists are kind of what they call
nihilistic they don't have any morals
they don't have any real standards they
have nothing that is you know as true
morally as one plus one equals two they
can't prove any of that so they just
have to kind of go with the motions and
what you said is absolutely true if you
were to ask them why is you know this
crime wrong morally why is you know
theft wrong morally
they don't have an answer for it so I
think that is that is a an amazing point
I think a huge stronghold that religious
and God-fearing people have over the
atheists that just that alone
yeah so we're gonna have to break our
fast fairly soon we're coming on
close to uh 10 to 15 minutes left in the
Stream and I think it's only fair that
we open the floor up to you guys and ask
is there anything about Islam that
confuses you or any kind of maybe
misconceptions or misunderstandings that
you have
uh I mean I can go first what is your
guyses and you guys can answer them
individually what do you think is the
single greatest argument for the
existence of God
oh that's easy
very easy that's so very easy you see I
didn't think I think I think in my head
I was like this gonna get it
easy one bro let's hear it let's hear it
um and you guys are smart you guys are
smart guys I know that so if you want to
push back because I'm going to make the
argument very simple please do so
you both come from your own parents
right and they come from their parents
they come from their parents and you get
to the first you know human or animal on
the Earth but they can only exist
because the Earth exists why does the
Earth exist because of something else
the thing that made the Earth why does
that exist because of something else and
you keep going back until you get to a
point let's say the beginning of the
universe now this is a crucial moment in
this chain
you have to ask the question where did
the universe come from if the universe
came from something that is not like a
god figure right so the universe was
created and the thing that made the
universe was also created you have to
take another step back what created that
thing and you cannot do that uh infinity
you can't go in infinitely back because
that would mean an infinite amount of
things would have to exist before us and
if I which it might seem like I'm
starting to do say an infinite amount of
words before I let you speak then you
would never speak so likewise if an
infinite amount of things have to come
into existence before we exist then we
would never exist but we do which means
it goes back to one single place now the
second crucial part this one single
place that this chain of you know
existence is goes back to cannot have a
beginning because that would make it
created
uh which means it's uncreated and it has
to have the ability the capacity to
sustain itself and be independent and
also to create other things like the
universe or whatever made the universe
so this is a very simple argument for
God just using basic logic and you come
to the conclusion without using any
religion or any religious text that you
have one being who's Eternal who is most
likely infinite or very the most
powerful thing that exists that had no
beginning and that created everything
that exists and has the you know
creative capacity and ability and all of
that stuff and I think maybe there's a
few traits that I'm missing but that's a
very simple explanation of it
I love that example that that's the
that's also my go-to it's like I don't
know exactly what is the truth or
anything like that but that's my proof
that something exists like I said like
how did the big bang happen right like
it couldn't just happen right and I love
that example and that that's what makes
me believe it also and many many people
today like a lot of atheists they
believe that you know the universe came
into existence or created itself
but the flaw in that thinking is
literally in that statement that if the
universe came into existence which we
can actually date when it happened then
it couldn't have created itself
um yeah I think my only pushback is
um is because something isn't
explainable doesn't mean that it can't
be explained eventually and we see this
through science you know people thought
the the Earth orbit didn't orbit the sun
they thought the sun orbited the Earth
and you know through science we further
and further and further our knowledge so
my only thing is
nobody should start with a definitive
statement like well what about the big
bang I don't think that's the argument I
think the argument is more well keep
going keep going keep going okay big
bands explain sure keep going keep going
as you said
things can't infinitely happen it has to
stop and then when it does stop you say
okay well how did this happen and I
think the argument for God is is
explainable in terms of a Creator but I
think how do you say okay what's the
argument for one God what's the argument
for not being three why is there not ten
why is there not a hundred why does it
even have to be a God can it not just be
um like whatever you know I mean why
does it have to be and then you say why
is Islam right
right or Christianity right or Judaism
why which one's right and then maybe
none of them are right yeah you know
what I mean so what's I guess that's the
progression of the conversation why
would you say that Islam right we've
established and I think we all agree
that sure something had to have started
it now why did a law started start yeah
and a lot of people are sensitive about
the word God too so we could just say a
creator for now sure
okay so uh can you repeat this specific
question because I don't want to not
answer
um my question is so I think we've all
established that something had to have
created something can't be an infinite
cycle
so what's the argument for the creators
uh in Islam Allah creating uh life I see
so why is it Allah as opposed to like
the trinity
well not even the Trinity maybe that's
wrong maybe yeah any other conception of
God yeah I see okay so actually it boils
down to it boils down to to one chapter
in the Quran called Surah
and I'm going to recite it in Arabic a
little bit and inshallah I'll say in
English
and actually there's a brother right
here I am the Warner may Allah bless you
bro he um on our shooter podcast he
recited the same exact Surah so I'm
gonna try and compete but his voice is a
lot better Allah
he says say he is Allah the one and only
Ahad is the one without a second
the self-sufficient and our Summit
actually means the one who doesn't
depend on anything
or anyone but everything that exists
ultimately depends upon him let me yell
it while amulet he does not beget nor
was he begotten so he didn't come from
anything and he doesn't give birth he's
not like a biological physical creature
like us
and there is nothing even similar
comparable to him in any way and now
this goes back to the argument
that and this is the by the way the
basic definition of God in Islam this is
what we refer to God as being and when
we walk through the argument we see that
we outline basically those
characteristics just with simple logic
so and I'll talk about him being one as
opposed to two in in a bit but for
example being self-sufficient in the way
that everything that depends or sorry
everything that that exists depends upon
you ultimately is like that causal chain
that only exists because of God
right everything in that chain only
exists because of God ultimately because
that's what it goes back to and uh
there's nothing even comparable to him
is because everything that exists like
you like all of us here the five of us
the laptops that we're using the lights
that were using the home the Earth
everything
it depends on something else and comes
from something else so we're dependent
for lack a better word and God is
necessary right we oh don't we're not
necessary We Exist because of something
else God just exists because he's God
necessary so there's nothing even
comparable to him so that's why we would
say that the Islamic understanding of
God is triumphant over I'd say the other
major religions as opposed to maybe not
Judaism because it's very similar in
Judaism but if you look at
and I'm gonna like in and pardon me I
don't mean to be rude but for the sake
of time I'm going to liken Christianity
to Hinduism meaning that they have
different persons or gods that they
worship but they ultimately say it goes
back to one God that's what the Hindus
believe as well that God's plan to
Millions the issue with this is you
can't have more than one all-powerful
being
because then neither of them would be
all-powerful why is there why is that an
argument yeah so think about it like
this
if you're all-powerful right you have no
limitations
right but at the same time you're
limited against this other being
that you cannot overtake them because
they're also all-powerful
wait I'm trying to conceptualize that it
might take a second bro my rendering
speed's a little slow on that no no
worries bro take your time take your
time if you so my thing is like
if you maybe it isn't all powerful in
terms of infinite power maybe it's just
enough power to create life right so
like I guess there's just so much uh I
guess what I'm saying if I want to sum
it up because there's I could be a
little long about this what about this
it's kind of more
what
why I know I know you explained it
because you need to be dependent on God
and he is necessary for us to be here
yeah but why it didn't really answer why
Islam sure Islam might be the most
logical I'd have to do my research but
even if we go off that point it's the
most logical yeah
why it's not 100 right but that's where
the faith comes in isn't it like that's
I think I actually think that's a bit of
a misconception I think the evidence is
for Islam are so concrete that nobody
can actually reject it logically or
rationally and it basically boils down
to this argument which has multiple
evidences for it but I'm gonna I'm gonna
try and make it very simple
sure
we believe God is real now
if God is real that opens up the
possibilities of Islam or other
religions or a religion being sent from
God to our us as humans and that
wouldn't be too unlikely being that we
exist and we seek these kind of answers
to begin with and we were created by God
so when you look at Islam and you look
at the prophet Muhammad peace upon him
you know God exists which is already
like a prerequisite first step now it's
a matter of is the prophet Muhammad
peace peace and blessings be upon him a
true prophet of God
or not and now you really only have
three options either he was truthful he
spoke the truth or he was crazy or he
was a liar
and when you go through his life you'll
find that the only possible conclusion
you can come to is that he was speaking
the truth because by his life he was
clearly not crazy in any in any regard
the people never actually believed he
was crazy that was sometimes just an
excuse they would throw out but they
would trust him with their belongings
his actual enemies would say you know I
have some gold can you hold on to it
that's how much they trusted him so they
knew he wasn't crazy and they knew he
wasn't lying either and one example of
this
is
um the prophet peace upon him there was
a time where one of his signs actually
his sons actually passed away
and when his son passed away the Moon
and the Sun eclipsed so the people
started saying wow the son of the
Prophet passed away and God caused the
moon and the sun to Eclipse because of
that
did the prophet peace be upon him turn
around and say yep I'm the prophet of
God and that's what God did for me and
my son no
he said both the sun and the moon are
signs from Allah and they don't eclipse
for the death of anyone even the son of
a prophet
why would a liar not seize that
opportunity
and say yep God Did It For Me
on top of that we saw how much he he
worked and he struggled and he strived
he was a father he was a caretaker he
was a husband he was a leader uh he had
times where he was very rich in his life
and he had times where he gave
everything to the Muslims and the
community and he was very poor despite
him being the leader of of that Nation
and on top of that like the cherry on
top is all the prophecies that he made
have you guys looked into the Prophecies
of Islam before
I don't think so I don't think so not
yet I think that I think that's going to
be a really good reaction video for you
guys next just just look up the
prophecies from the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him and it is absolutely
astonishing I'll just give a few
examples
he said
for example there will come a time where
like the Barefoot Arab like Bedouin
sheep herding people will compete in
building tall towers now back yeah
we have reactivity like that I remember
hearing that yeah yeah yeah
I can't think maybe he remembers who
Adam wait can you explain it then what
do you remember in a bad way he
literally said a part of the exact video
of like and then you brought
um Dubai into it and how they're like
filling upwards and things like that
oh yeah I think we've reacted something
like that yeah yeah yeah and there are
there are like numerous examples that
specify time that specify place so when
you really when a person is genuine
sincere they want to look at the
evidence it's all there they can go and
see a man who lived 1400 years ago who
is just a regular person until he was
you know given Revelation from God came
with all these almost insane sounding
predictions that specify time plays
conditions and they're also accurate to
the point where there are only a few
that are in the process of happening or
have yet to come
damn
I mean that's I mean we've looked at
stuff at the mathematical Miracle of the
Quran like stuff like that where it's
kind of like you know showing that what
is in the Quran has already happened and
as you said could or will happen
um and yeah like I mean I can't argue
any of that point because I'm not
educated enough but what I will say is
that
um you know
if Islam is the most logical
um religion then and it's you know
brought this sense of community to a lot
of people and you know even bringing in
someone like me who comes from a country
where it's 99 Catholic in words
Ukraine's very uh Christian
so yeah if you can bring all of us
together and you know have a discussion
or learn more you know make more people
Muslim uh or bring people and make
people better in general I think it's a
good thing anyway
absolutely and that's personally why I
like you guys very much I see your
content as very genuine authentic I
think you guys are very bright and
genuine young men and I appreciate that
very much and uh I I guarantee that the
Muslim and you know your Muslim audience
as well probably really appreciates that
now I have one final question for myself
and that is do you guys potentially see
yourselves accepting Islam at some point
in the future
I can't even say
I can as we further learn about it I'm
sure there will be like a turning point
where I'm like you know what it's
starting to make a lot of sense to me
and I'm just not at that point as of
right now so I can't say anything for
sure
but the more we learn I guess the more
we find out yeah I just have no idea
like I you you know why it is it's
because like like even hearing you or Dr
Zakir just the amount of knowledge that
you have like I'm a very meticulous like
I would I would have to I think about
every scenario I would have to sit there
and run through every single argument of
why Islam could not be false in order to
do my shahada which I don't even know if
I could possibly do but if I do that and
I get to that conclusion then yes
but that would take a lot and a lot of
learning yeah you know that that that's
amazing you want to know why that's
amazing man it's because we just had a
brother on who just accepted Islam his
name is Bobby I don't know yeah
his reversion actually yeah yeah he if
you want you can go watch our our
interview with him he was saying that he
did exactly what you just said that he
was very meticulous he looked at every
single argument he he studied it for
probably years we had him on our podcast
I think maybe two years ago a year and a
half ago and
you know a year and a half later two
years later he finally accepted Islam
the whole time just looking into it so
again you know it goes back to what I
mentioned before it's a beautiful thing
and it shows you know how genuine you
guys are and I just trust that you know
in your journey while you're learning
more about Islam that you keep us in
mind and if you have any question please
do not hesitate to reach out to us oh
yeah thank you very much man 100 of
course of course I want to pass the
fourth to uh fight and on Hill
honestly man
[Music]
what happens all the time it literally
happens to us yeah there's a quick uh
comment I wanted to read up from brother
will have the winner Romney looking like
a final boss right now let's go I love
my buddy
what do you want to say
man I just wanted to
highlight something and just bring
something else to the table because you
said that
you didn't know if if Islam was 100 the
truth and then both of you were saying
you know if you guys look into it just a
little bit more then perhaps you know he
gets to the point where things start
making more sense than you could then
start to see yourself as a Muslim right
so when you guys were kids do you guys
remember playing the game uh called the
telephone game yeah
you remember you were you would say
someone or say something to someone and
then it would go around in the circle
until it got back to you and like let's
say you said banana and by the time I
got you if it was like I don't know like
apple or something like this it was game
over right like they messed it up yeah
so think about this
if if there is a God if there is this uh
This original thing that has created
everything and everyone
then it would only make sense that if we
were created there's a there's a reason
there's a there's a purpose to all this
because nothing is just a coincidence
nothing is by accident so if there's a
purpose would the Creator not try to
explain that to us
simple question yes or no
would the Creator try to explain it to
us if the Creator created us um I mean
depends on the credit the credit creates
you and then be like you know what we'll
really test them we'll really test them
maybe give them a few hints like you
know the Quran and yeah and that's okay
that's a better example better example
this is a vacuum cleaner right that is a
vacuum cleaner yeah all right all right
when this thing let's say this thing was
first made right right it comes with an
instruction manual
for how to use it correct yeah so then
it would only make sense that in this
life if we're going there's also an
instruction manual for what is happening
here
hmm
okay now now let's say let's say this is
true let's just say figuratively
speaking this is true
how would this instruction manual get
down to people
of course the the Creator would have to
explain he would have to say that okay
this is what this is this is what the
purpose of this is this is why you hear
all this stuff so it's essentially the
telephone game and think of it as God
has been trying to tell us from the
beginning of time why we're here
what the purpose of all this is and
where we're going I mean why else would
we have these na questions correct
yeah I I agree I think I think we we
established that there has to be a
Creator I think now it just turns to as
we talked about before is that
it's that that's where you delve into
and I think even before I started
looking into Islam my whole life I
believe yeah there's something so I
don't think my uh I obviously my
knowledge expanded but I don't think my
initial base reality changed where I
didn't believe in anything specifically
um in any specific religion but I've
always believed that something's there
and coming back to your point of it's a
telephone game where you know
communication also gets misinterpreted
and misheard and everything you know
Gabriel coming down the angel telling
Muhammad getting that information
relating it to everybody some might body
might go into another Islamic group you
know you have that what is it the 10 of
like the different Muslims who believe
what is it I forget I don't know there's
like another Muslim group
I think we learned about that I forget
what what the exception is but
um but yeah like so information
definitely gets relayed in different
ways so yeah it's again I understand
that's a good analogy yeah it's kind of
like if you get a vacuum cleaner and it
comes with like multiple sets of
instructions and you're like well
whichever makes more sense yeah that's
the one
so you've got to read it
yeah you gotta read and find out it
makes the most sense 100 bro but taking
a step back uh taking this step back if
God has been playing this telephone game
with humans then okay he starts to relay
the message
and the moment someone messes it up
because as humans bro we have egos we
tend to mess things up real quick
so the moment he misses or someone
messes something up that's it it's game
over he moves on to the next person or
the next group of people this is why bro
this is why when you start to look into
different religions different spiritual
practices different cultural beliefs you
will find that they all have similar
things they all have pieces of the
puzzle and then when you start looking
into it further you start to see that
some of them have more pieces of the
puzzle than others now why is it it's
because bro they lasted longer in the
game before messing it up
um
so if this is true
then if someone completed the game if
someone got the message and then relayed
it perfectly at the end they won't like
they completed the game
if you look into Islam bro
you will find that it has for the most
part every single piece of the puzzle
and even in the Quran itself it makes a
statement the Creator God makes a
statement that I have completed my
favorite Point I've completed your
religion like it's it's complete it's
done
so with this being said man
I just invite you guys to continue to
look into it and please please like feel
free to message us ask us any questions
throughout this journey because it's
it's definitely a journey book
do you guys both have a copy of the
Quran
no no no oh bro Saskatchewan's listen
Saskatchewan's our neighbor bro we'll
send you one inshallah this week wait
where where are you guys oh well you
guys are close then yeah we're in
Toronto bro yeah oh my God I saw you
guys in Dubai you guys have been
traveling around
appreciate it yeah thank you so much and
yeah we'll send you guys a copy of the
Quran one for each of you will touch
base outside and guys this has been
amazing honestly
um exceeded my expectations again you
guys are great uh you should have done
amazing honestly on this podcast and uh
I really hope that we can do this again
maybe in a few months when you guys
learn a little bit more if you have more
questions and then by then you know
we'll we'll start our road game we'll
get the beard game strong it'll be fine
let's go yeah yeah we'll start we might
need more than three months I'll be real
soon but like we'll get there in the end
insha Allah all right so final this is
the Super Chat final question we'll take
before we end the stream because we do
have to go breaking our fast because it
is the month of Ramadan Brothers Owen
asked before why Allah why why did Allah
create people and what did he want from
us I hope you guys tell them the answer
thanks Fen from Kuai may Allah bless you
well very clearly why did Allah create
mankind Allah he says in the Quran that
he did not create the Jinn or mankind
except to worship Him and now you might
be thinking okay so I sit here and I
pray and that's not just what worship is
the Islamic concept of worship is is
beautiful in my humble opinion because
it's not just who you sacrifice your
your money for and given charity on you
know on behalf of her for it's not just
who you pray to and who you ask to
relieve you of pain and and you know
give you reward and so on and so forth
It's also who you obey it's who you let
guide your life who you take as the
objective arbitrator of reality and and
morality like we were discussing before
so that that's what we are made to do as
human beings we're created just to fully
submit to and worship God and Obey him
in every single way even you know giving
daoba calling people to Islam you know
smiling having good manners these are
all things that God has
um
prescribed for Muslims
yeah
I mean that's it's a good explanation I
mean I can't you can't really argue
without the knowledge I'd have to I have
to look into everything and you know
I've been like thinking like you know
maybe let's react to a few others like
I've been looking at Young Don I was
like man we gotta talk to him too like
talk in all different perspectives and
coming to a conclusion of you know where
where we stand but you know I've one
final question super quick yeah because
I've been I've been asked to ask you
guys this a lot can you eat pork and
Janelle
so there's nothing
there's there's
yeah there's there's nothing in Jannah
that's Haram there's nothing in general
so if there's four things
all right bro repeat repeat after me
bro it's guys it's been a pleasure for
real thank you guys so much for
attending and I hope again inshallah we
can do this real soon everyone for
attending may Allah bless you all
immensely may Allah forgive us for any
mistakes or slips any bad is from us and
from shaytan and any God is from Allah
alone may Allah forgive us for our slips
and except from us are good deeds and
make us leaders for the righteous I mean
with that being said
and I'll see you guys in the next one